sarah everard had been visiting her
friend's house in south london
when she vanished on the 3rd of march
while walking home through clapham
common
after an increasingly intensive search
in the days that followed
her body was discovered in woodland near
the town of ashford in kent
a week after she disappeared some of
sarah's family were in court
to hear a serving metropolitan police
officer plead guilty to her kidnap and
rape
legal counsel for pc wayne cousins told
the court
his client also accepted responsibility
for her killing
but cousins was not asked to enter a
plea
on a third count of murder as the court
awaits
medical records on the 48 year old
appearing on a video link from belle
marsh prison wayne cousins sat
slumped forward for most of the
20-minute hearing
when asked how he pleaded to a charge of
kidnapping sarah everard on the 3rd of
march
he said guilty sir and again on a second
count of raping sarah everard between
the 2nd
and 10th of march he replied guilty sir
the disappearance and death of sarah
everard sparked a nationwide debate
over women's safety at a huge outpouring
of sympathy
which saw thousands including the
duchess of cambridge
visit a makeshift memorial on clapham
common
pc cousins will appear in court again on
the 9th of july
after psychiatric and psychological
reports have been received
mark white sky news at the old bailey